hi I'm Alex and I'm Zoya and today we're
going to be getting creative and
designing our Dream kitchens using the
Sims
and find a way to merge our designs and
find the middle grounds
first things first I loved zoya's
kitchen design because of the elements
that overlapped with mine I thought that
was so funny the hot tub in the middle
the bar the pride flag the statue of the
woman Alex's Sims kitchen was very much
Alex it was ridiculous and funny the
actual hard work that goes to building
the dream kitchen I think we have our
work cut out for us our kitchen designs
are so drastically different and we're
really struggling to meet them in the
middle so I think we have to call in
some help to professional help
professional help let's call Connie I'm
here hi Connie hi guys how are you we
are so glad that you took our call
because we are struggling so Connie we
sent you both of our Sims kitchen
designs what did you think first off
perfect no notes
amazing thank you yeah thanks okay call
it a day I feel like The Sims is a
really unique tool because one of the
biggest problems that I have whenever
I'm designing a space is I can't
visualize it yeah so did this help you
guys actually see like the full picture
better 100 it was really cool to play
around on the Sims and use it for inspo
for real life they both
they both dark minimalist those are
definitely all your Vibes and then with
Alex we saw very fun eccentric in a good
way very good vibes I definitely know
why you guys are slightly panicking
looking at them whenever we're trying to
like combine our style with somebody
else's the first thing that you want to
do you want to think about how different
they are that's like what our brains
normally go to instead of thinking about
what are the things that we have in
common you guys actually have a lot of
things that you do have in common even
though it may not feel like it when it
comes down to that you both want
something that works functionally when
you look at your picture there is a
glaringly obvious starting point you
both have a hot tub if we think about
the hot tub more as a concept instead of
something literal I think we could go
more Beach as an inspiration instead of
going just straight up a hot tub you
might be thinking like themed restaurant
Vibes it doesn't have to be that because
Zoya likes more darker tones we like
going in that more kind of aesthetic we
can think of beach tones as a way to
utilize color while also making it more
earthy and natural so I would say
incorporate things like teals and stuff
like that that still has that almost
like darker kind of aesthetic and Vibe
but it also has like the bright fun pop
of colors you both have plants plants
are a good way to add like life to a
space because I think that you guys can
incorporate into like the cabinets and
things some like darker Hues so if
you're feel like it's feeling too cold
and Stark whenever it goes into that
dark kind of place then I think plants
are a great way to add like that pop of
color but still having that more natural
feel you guys also like open shelves too
right I like a mixture of both I think
you guys like two different versions of
open shelving but I think that that's
another Common Ground place to come
together on Alex loves open shelves and
to put as many things as you can put on
an open job Zoya you like an open shelf
because it gives a display for the
pieces that you want people to see I
love that switching the mindset into
like what do we have in common then you
have something to work from well thank
you so much Connie this really helped
just remember have fun don't panic I'm
here if you need anything okay thank you
I'm feeling great about the call I think
she had some really great points I think
both of us are willing to bend a little
bit in those ways as long as we feel we
are both in the kitchen like represented
within the kitchen having like symbolic
Beach I guess more than this maybe not
sand on the floor maybe neutral colors
yeah instead of the hot tub in the
middle or water will just add Cabinetry
color with the blues or the teals do you
feel like one of us is willing to bend a
bit more than the other I think that's
you we have open shelving so we can put
blue bowls or cups low risk yeah so you
can switch them out I'm most excited to
find these little elements that tie us
both in in a unique way and make us
really fall in love with this kitchen
design we spend most of our time in the
kitchen so it is exciting to think about
making it our our actual dream space
we're going less tchotchke more Chic
but the gnomes are stay absolutely not I
know Zoya she's an Aries and she's gonna
wanna get her way but I'm a Taurus and I
am stubborn we'll see what happens let's
get designing the house
you glitched at the end